[Musik]
breaking news
breaking news ein tödlicher einsatz die
polizei hat einen mann in einem hotel in
berüchtigen frankfurter bahnhofsviertel
erschossen mitten in der nacht wurde die
polizei zu diesem hotel hier in der
moselstraße gerufen was genau sich darin
abspielte das ist noch nicht bekannt
gleis nur spezialkräfte chancen bei dem
einsatz auf einen mann der später an
seinen schweren verletzungen starb
und 84 das ganze abgespielt und die
polizei die spricht von einer
bedrohungslage die dort stattgefunden da
müssen wir noch nachreichen was darüber
bekannt ist unsere reporterin jessica
verleih ist genau dort im frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel jessica kannst du uns
schon ein bisschen genaueres zu dieser
bedrohungslage sagen also warum gab es
da diesen
spezialeinsatz der frankfurter polizei
dazu kann ich nichts sagen ist immer
noch das bekannt was bislang bekannt ist
man sieht hinter mir das hotel das lka
kommt er immer wieder raus spuren werden
gesichert woran es wirklich lage was
wirklich passiert ist weiß man nicht wie
viele schüsse abgefeuert wurden weiß man
auch noch nicht genau also momentan ist
da kein sind keine weiteren details kann
ich zu der tat oder was genau passiert
ist wie sehr die bedrohungslage
eskaliert es um was genau auf da
passiert ist jessica wir sehen im
hintergrund da laufen die ermittlungen
um vier uhr morgens hat sich das ganze
abgespielt ja wie verändert das auch die
stimmung dort im bahnhofsviertel ein
viertel das jahr weit über die grenzen
von frankfurt aus berühmt ist
also ganz ehrlich jetzt verändert die
stimmung überhaupt gar nicht es ist so
klingt ein bisschen schockierend wenn
ich das hier zu sagen aber das kommt man
so langsam vor wie daily business ich
liebe meine stadt wirklich aber das
bahnhofsviertel ist wirklich so ein
viertel wo ich sage ich fühle mich hier
nicht sicher als frau schon gar nicht es
ist das eingang zu unserer stadt es ist
eine katastrophe
diese die die komplette lage ist hier
einfach nicht im griff ich kann euch das
mal so ein bisschen rum zeigen die das
hier aus sieht man kommt hier lang man
wird angesprochen angepöbelt überall
sind irgendwie junkies die am boden
sitzen nickerchen machen auch in welchen
ist an sich eine spritze in die vene
jagen hier ist alles schmutzig es alles
dreckig es stinkt unfassbar die sind
überall glasscherben ich bin vorher
einfach nur diese straße hier entlang
gelaufen da kam eine wasserflasche aus
glas vom balkon aus runter geknallt und
ein passant hat es fast getroffen und er
hat es so zurückgesprungen und wusste
gar nicht wie ihm geschieht hier kann
man auch gucken jetzt gegen überall müll
hier liegen menschen hier sind auch noch
handschuhe die auf dem boden liegen ich
weiß nicht wie gut man das sieht
wahrscheinlich von dem einsatz gestern
das weiß ich aber nicht sicher hier ist
auch etwas was aussieht wie ein
blutfleck da bin ich dran vorbei
gelaufen fand ich sehr schockierend so
sieht man auch noch ein scherbenmeer
vielen liegt etwas was so aussieht wie
ein blutiger verband also us spannungs
viertel ist wirklich wirklich ein
sorgenkind und
es klingt traurig aber es ist wie immer
ich glaube es überrascht kein mensch
starke worte von unser bild reporterin
in frankfurt die sagt sie liebt ihre
stadt aber gleichzeitig angeekelt
angewidert und auch mit mit angst geht
sie in dieses frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel jessica zeigt uns
nochmal dieses hotel ja man muss ja
sagen in anführungsstrichen hotel das
ist jetzt nicht gerade ja wahnsinnig
angesagte absteige dort ich versuche das
bild das zu drehen weil ich das so halte
ich hier das ist das hotel hier steht
das
auto vom lkh hier sind noch die ganzen
ermittler die die ganze ganze tross
gehen das ist das wo sind hotel hier
keine ahnung wer da bock hat und dazu
kommen die fenster sind geöffnet und den
meisten zellen sondern sind so braune
sehr schwere vorhänge davor
stehen auch schuhe keine an und wem die
gehören also es ist jetzt ja so sieht es
hier aus aber so sieht es ein bisschen
auch vor jedem hotel aus
bahnhofsviertel
hinweisschilder ist von diesem viertel
das scheint so ein bisschen außer
kontrolle geraten zu sein was dein
eindruck jetzt auch fest macht in diesem
fall aber auch mit blick auf die
vergangenen monate vergangenen wochen
hat die polizei dieses viertel das ja
wirklich im herzen frankfurts liegt
überhaupt noch im griff dass das möglich
dass das ist das weiß man irgendwann hat
es geschmeckt hat die ganze situation
noch ein bisschen schlimmer gemacht auch
wenn das blöd die bahn uns heute nacht
wurde auch abgesagt damit man auch dass
das daran hängt das wirklich hier ist
viel schlimmer geworden ist ich weiß
nicht ob ihr euch erst letzte woche ist
ja oder 2 auch ein video aufgetaucht wo
drei männer beieinander standen und
einfach einen der mit armen verschränkt
vor den stand und sich ganz normal mit
den unterhalt nicht so dermaßen von
ausgeknockt wurde erst mit dem kopf so
dass das aber zeigen gerade jessica wir
haben die bilder nochmal vorliegen du
sagst ist es ist gerade knapp zwei
wochen her hier sehen sie die bilder
nochmal also ihre szenen dort aus dem
bahnhofsviertel sowie jessica das gerade
geschildert hat einer dieser männer wird
er ausgeknockt und dann wird einfach in
die taschen gegriffen dann wird der mann
ausgenommen aus glaubt vorne sind sie
eine frau die mit einer decke
vorbeiläuft für die das offenbar völlig
normal ist auch und andere passanten
laufen auch einfach vorbei das ist der
alltag offenbar der guckt man nicht
genauer hin ist froh dass man damit
nichts zu tun hat eine schlägerei die
dort ja tatsächlich alltag ist im
frankfurter bahnhofsviertel ein mann der
aus gelockt wird dann liegen gelassen
wird wird doch den aufprall da vom kopf
und die menschen die drum rum laufen und
sich im grunde nicht groß drum scheren
das ist dort ja die schilder ist jessica
der alltag dort im viertel ja ich weiß
nicht wie in dem man den ton auch
wirklich hört ich habe es wirklich mit
ton gehört und diese auf schlag das
klang wirklich als werden blumentopf auf
den boden gefallen und denn man ist ja
auch in der sekunde einfach nicht mehr
da nicht mehr bewusst was verleih sich
ja nicht mal mehr versucht irgendwie
aufzufangen oder so und dann diese leute
sind da so
ich will nicht sagen ignorant weil ich
nicht mal wirklich den vorwerfen möchte
dass sie überhaupt noch sehen was da
passierte sind einfach blind geworden
sind die komplette situation ist kommt
mir vor wie so ein eigenes eine eigene
stadt in der stadt unsere eigene gesetze
langsam herrschen und ja man fragt sich
so ein bisschen wann tut mal jemand was
und dann tut man wirklich jemand was und
wie lange wird das dauern und was muss
man tun damit einfach besser wird
ganz kurz nachher gut ich glaube auch
werden weiß gar nicht was mit dem mann
dann letztendlich passiert ist es aber
auch ein krankenhaus gelandet ist oder
ob es gut geht es auch noch so eine
sache keiner weiß hier irgendwann
bei uns live zugeschaltet aus frankfurt
wo eine mann von der polizei erschossen
wurde in dem hotel hinter ihr die
ermittlungsarbeiten wir sind noch im
vollen gange gleichzeitig schockierende
schilderungen über ein viertel eher im
hintergrund sind die großen bank
trauernicht weit davon entfernt das
bahnhofsviertel in frankfurt ist das
völlig außer kontrolle zu sein scheint
jessica danke für deine schilderung
[Musik]